-Welcome, back,
everybody,
We're talking with
Sigourney Weaver
who stars in the new movie
"Call Jane,"
which opens this Friday.
You're fantastic in this movie.
The movie is fantastic
and very important,
oddly for these times,
now.
But can you explain
who you play,
and what the movie is about?
-So "Call Jane" was the name of
a clandestine organization
put together by women
to help women
obtain safe illegal abortions.
And it's this group of women who
just come together to, you know,
with respect,
and real love and care,
to take all these different
women, with different reasons,
but good reasons,
who had to take advantage
of that procedure.
And we follow the great
Elizabeth Banks...
-She's fantastic.
...who plays a
housewife named Joy.
You follow her story.
And she has a kind of
political awakening.
And I'm hoping that the movie,
because it sort of --
first of all, it's very
entertaining.
It's not like taking, like, a
bottle of medicine or anything.
-No, no, no.
-You know, it's got jokes.
-Yes.
-Um, and...
and my character
is quite funny.
But, you know, we're hoping
that it will sort of
de politicize this,
remind people that the person
who's really at risk
is the woman,
and that she needs
all the support
and compassion
we can give her.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-It's...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
It's so -- when you see it,
you go, "Oh, my gosh."
The story is -- amazing, and
some intense moments, as well.
But then I was asking you,
when did you film this?
-Yeah, we filmed it
in the spring of '21.
So we -- we were not -- I was
not expecting Roe Versus Wade,
this thing had transformed
women's lives,
given them a chance
to control when they have
their families, and how many
children they have,
and, you know,
we didn't imagine that it could
be overturned in such a way.
-Yeah.
-And now we're --
this is unfortunately,
especially relevant.
And we're hoping that
in the midterms, you know,
that it will be very much
on people's minds,
and that this movie can help
encourage people to vote,
vote back our rights.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sigourney weaver
in "Call Jane."
Take a look at this.
-Okay.
-Well done, Jackie O.
I'm sorry that wasn't the
morning you expected.
-You read my mind, Doll.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Mm-mm-mm.
-I'm trying to quit.
-Why?
-Maybe I want to sing opera
in my next life.
-We have organizing meetings
on Thursdays.
That's the address.
[ Soft jazz music plays ]
♪♪
-I don't agree with
what you're doing.
-Sigourney weaver,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Call Jane" opens in
theaters this Friday.
Thank you so much
for being here.
We love it every time
you're here.
Sigourney weaver!
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.